soldiers are back on the streets of
ciudad Juarez it was common to see them
here from 2009 to 12 when it was an
epicenter of Mexico's violence and the
decades since things had calmed now the
murders are up again
if his mission is to reduce homicides
the second is reducing or beating street
level drug trafficking
it's just one area in Mexico where
violence has been exploding over the
last couple of months
the country's Southwest has been even
more turbulent than usual murders are up
by 20 percent in the coastal state of
Guerrero
and authorities have had to send in 1
200 troops to try and bring calm to
neighboring Michoacan in Jalisco state
criminal groups attacked police with
explosives this July gangsters are using
armored trucks too drones even mines
those caught in the middle continued to
die or simply vanish so far an estimated
112 000 people have disappeared since
former president Felipe Calderon began
his so-called war and Drugs in 2006.
five young men gone also in Jalisco
State this August was the latest case to
cause public outcry
the pain is so big we can't take it
anymore the days go on the hours and we
don't have anything concrete the
authorities haven't confirmed anything
their relatives recognize them in a
kidnap video but authorities are still
trying to find them or their bodies some
of Mexico's forensic Labs say that
they're overwhelmed by the sheer number
of remains this Cemetery in Guerrero is
full of unnamed victims I'm through at
all there's the knowledge that this
could get worse we're heading into an
election year in Mexico and as the
politicians battle at the urns so too do
the criminal groups that are often
behind them for power territory control
of the population in the past it's led
to a really bloody situation
but president Andres Manuel Lopez
obrador is seeing a different picture
according to government statistics
homicides dropped last year he says that
Nationwide those numbers continue to go
down
[Applause]
insecurity our strategy is working well
attending the causes of the violence and
applying the principle that peace is a
fruit of Justice federal crimes have
been reduced by 24 percent homicized by
70 percent
but in the country's hot spots criminal
groups seem as entrenched and combative
as ever while the Mexican state
continues to struggle to fight them John
Holman Al Jazeera Mexico City
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera